hi guys as most of you will know I am
currently studying computer game arts at
University however I am almost finished
with my degree I'm in third year and I'm
currently at home for Christmas break
and it's dawning on me that I only have
about 6 months left it's a little bit
scary but I figured I would share my
experience with you so far and then give
you a proper video on how I found
University and everything after I have
completed my degree hopefully got myself
a good one good we shall see so yeah
today it's gonna be a very chilled out
Q&A about my university experience
because whenever I tell people that I
study computer game arts they're always
pretty interested because it is a pretty
interesting subject especially with my
university because it's very all rounded
and they know a lots of degrees aren't
like that there's good and bad points to
it but basically in my course of
computer game arts we not only learn how
to make game art so concept arts using
Photoshop and things like that we also
learn how to 3d model that concept art
how to texture it a little bit about
rigging nothing really about animation
but we get to do that on our own time
and coding and putting it all together
in unity as well so basically it's a
course that teaches you how to be an
indie game developer which sounds pretty
awesome right sounds pretty overwhelming
yes but it is in my opinion totally
worth it for reasons that might be a
little bit controversial but we all talk
about it today through my responses to
your questions so basically I just asked
you guys a bunch of questions no no I
didn't know I didn't I asked you guys
for your questions on Twitter and I
asked you lovely patreon on discord chat
so let's start with you patreon Michael
Castilla asked when does UK university
start and when did you start developing
gains for Taba knee and tifinagh what
basically I have a game dev team in uni
which are the girls that I do all the
game dev stuff with and they're called
Tiffany and Tabitha not Tammany and
tiffith / what is that but they are
awesome awesome girls and I've made the
past three games with them UK University
starts in September most courses do not
all but most of them do so that's when I
started in September of 2016 15 15 huh
2015 that's so long ago now oh it's a
scary don't really think maybe and I
didn't actually meet Tabitha and Tiffany
until the beginning of second year and
I'm so glad that I did because I think
first year is where you're kind of
getting to know yourself getting to know
who you work well with who you don't
work well with what you might want to do
with your career you know in the second
and third years of what you want to kind
of focus more on and yeah I'm so lucky
that I met them because I was basically
a loner in the second year and then they
found me and they were like hey we need
a partner to make this next game with to
come with us and also yes she says yes
please please be my friends and ever
since then we've worked so well together
because they adore the modeling aspect
of things and I adore the coding and the
concept in so it is a great little trio
pairing that we've got going on you
could do did you do did you do and
actually I've said I was gonna be
patreon its first but there's a question
on Twitter that relates to that question
very well very so Ferb it's your name
but it's mugiwara seven four five hero
of time that's your little handle and
you said you're developing a game but
with three friends so is that difficult
yes hell yes especially because the last
couple of games that we've made we've
only had three months to make the game
in so it has been a lot of late nights
working through weekend
sweating non-stop but I don't know if
I'm doing something that I'm passionate
about I don't mind I will happily stay
up all night I will happily work few
weekends I'll happily spend all my time
on it because it's something that I
really want to see happen for instance
our sleep paralysis game Club plug can
buy it on the place so it's only 70 P
what that was made in three months and
it's all about three paralysis helping
people to understand what it's like to
have it and what it's all about and I'm
really proud of that I think I think us
as a team right super well to get that
game developed in three months and I'm
so excited to see it out on the
Playstore and it was actually my
lecturer who said he felt it was up to
standard to be on the Playstore so yeah
bigger your boost it was great but of
course yeah it's difficult it's
difficult just a that you should have at
least a game designer concept artist
character artists environment artists
and sometimes if you need it a GUI
artist so we have three people three
three three people so usually we just
will share the concepts arts I'm the
game designer
Tabitha's character artist and Tiffany
is the environment artist if you'd like
to see more on that in detail go check
out my second channel which is more
about the game development stuff that
I'm doing in university talks about the
game that we're wrecking on now talks
about it all in detail plugs everywhere
today let's move on to the mix - John
hey that kind of rhymed because I said
it's stupidly back to is the patreon so
if 196th asks what is the biggest
obstacle that you've faced while
developing a game with your teammates
such a good question oh man I think the
biggest one for us was probably
animation but just because we don't
actually get taught how to animate and
that also answers Laureates question
which was what do they teach in
animation
yeah they don't actually really teach
your animation you kind of get one
lesson on how to rig not enough rigging
is difficult I don't understand but I
mean there is a whole
animation subject in universities so if
you want to be doing that you probably
should have gone to study animation
instead so yeah that was pretty hard and
also just you know personal life gets in
the way sometimes and you need to kind
of put the project to one side and
remember to be friends as well and
that's one thing especially in the third
year I'm realizing I just want to spend
time with my teammates as friends as
well as work partners because they're
lovely people as well as hard workers
and I want to appreciate them for that
okay I'm really sorry for [ __ ] your
name as well but shows sue Hmong techie
nurse your handle is JC and base
basically you're saying that you're
trying to develop a game with your
friends and they're more creative and
you're a coder can I give you advice on
how to be more creative with your
approach Oh
you use the word artistic actually
artistic with your approach hmm it's
very interesting cuz I hear this quite a
bit you know that that coding is not
creative or that coders aren't creative
people and forever that has just
mind-boggling because before I even went
to uni I was a front-end developer I was
still coding but I still felt that I was
I was a creative person and I think the
coders are creative because if you give
them a problem to do or you want you
want some sort of functionality to
happen right there are so many different
ways to code that to make it happen so
you need to think of like the most the
most efficient way maybe even tweak it
along the way you can make some cool
stuff happen I think that's how most of
the really awesome game mechanics
happened I have an idea in my head of
what kind of game mechanics I won and
then as I'm coding it I realized that
maybe I can incorporate something else
into it or maybe I could make some
particles instantiate as this happens
and then it looks more like magic cool
and then I guess that's how you become
more artistic and creative with your
code because you're not just thinking
basic math you're thinking okay how is
the user going to interact with this
what other way could could they interact
with this like what what fun different
things could happen through the
interaction process that that is
creative and
mystic I think that's the only yoni
advice I can give you really um being a
coder does not make you any less
creative than anyone else on the team if
anything I think it might even give you
more creativity because you are the one
with the control at the end you know
they could have all these visions and
ideas but if they can't call it and make
it make it happen in the real world then
it's never gonna happen so it's up to
you to to be creative in that way I hope
that makes sense I'm just gonna rambling
lessard phallus and your handle is valid
Leopard let no I'm just gonna give up oh
so bad things mean you said what are the
most frustrating parts about the game
making process mmm
honestly for me actually it's being
judged by the rest of the of the class
and that might just be a me thing but I
I fall in love deeply and solely with my
ideas I'm a very passionate person have
you not this and fin game designer I'm
the one who comes up with the initial
idea the narrative the reason behind you
know all that kind of stuff that people
will ask a lot of questions about maybe
judge and some will think it's great
another's fun and you know it's it's
kind of intimidating to explain that to
a lot of people get maybe a lot of
negative feedback and trying to explain
your idea without having a prototype in
the very beginning stages can be really
difficult that's what I kind of just
like to forget about that you know
obviously do the presentations and do
what I've got to do do the pitch but
then don't take anything too seriously
until I get to the prototype stage and
I've got something physical for them to
play with and see that's when they'll
get your idea more because once it's an
ideas in your head you you can't really
get out until you just get it out you
know what I mean you can try
you can't make kids be quiet okay Edward
Westmoreland concert has a really good
question about YouTube as well saying I
know sometimes you struggle with
balancing YouTube and university what
would you say about someone who wants to
go down this path has it helped you has
it hindered it's been it's been a weird
ride basically actually one of my
lecturers left University it was my
coding lecturer we were without a coding
lecture for like two months it was
difficult but he laughed and he took me
off to one side and he said you have the
potential to be like one of the best
students in the class however I feel
like your YouTube and everything you do
outside of uni it's holding you back
that really made me think for a while
but the more that I think about it the
more that I realized that this YouTube
stuff me working here me getting out
there and interviewing game developers
me meeting people through YouTube and
getting opportunities over to me because
of YouTube I'm constantly getting better
because I'm making videos it means so
much more than just a grade on a piece
of paper I'm not saying I'm not striving
for a first it'd be amazing if I could
get that but if I could have say a - one
or two - which is basically I don't know
a good good medium a good medium great
as a long with a bigger presence in the
gaming community and game developers and
videos to show for it and interviews of
people showing that I I understand when
I'm talking about I'm interested in it
and I'm already putting my toes in the
field that I want to be in I think that
makes more sense to me I don't know
because you there's so many people that
come out of university and they've got a
great degree but they're not quite sure
how to apply themselves in that field or
they're not quite sure how to get the
foot in the door or you know then
they've got a wreck on their CV and
their website and I've already got that
and this whole YouTube channel works ask
my CV it just makes sense in my mind
anyway so yes it's so diff
got to try and do both this at the same
time but I know that after University
it's going to be worth it so worth it I
do kind of wish I could just dedicate
myself to one thing because then I could
know that I could protect myself on that
thing but I think spreading myself out a
bit thin on both things will help me out
better in the long run I hope you
enjoying the giggles in the background
have you learnt any exciting concepts or
mechanics that you're going to use in
games in the future well I will let you
in on a little something mile with your
handle me resume music I am actually
making a game now incorporating Facebook
yes
Facebook and it will be pulling in your
personal information so like your
profile picture and your friend's name
and your gender and it puts in the game
not just as a leaderboard like you're
walking around a 3d world and your
pictures there or your friend's name is
there
imagine PT I mean no no don't don't but
this is where I got the idea from I was
like imagine if you could play PT game
as horrifying as PT the only thing that
would make it more scary is if you
realized that on the table there was a
portrait of you it would be so freaky
and using the Facebook SDK seems to be
working at the moment because there's an
SDK for unity so yes that's is exciting
and the last question is from Alan
Malcolm White Eagle UK and he asked me
about my future which is kind of scary
he asked me what role do I think I will
put myself in when I get to a studio
artist producer the future is a scary
thing honestly I think I think game
design I really like being game designer
but it just seems like a harder job role
to actually get into the way to get into
being a 3d modeler or concept artist
there just seems to be a lot more
information on how to it how to become
those roles I'd love to just be
something kind of hybrid you know maybe
help them with their marketing as well
as two bit of code here and there as
let's do that voice acting as well let's
do this I thought that I don't know I
think this is why I would much prefer to
work in like a little indie studio where
perhaps like I just I could just have my
hands in multiple different pockets but
yeah right now I am enjoying the coding
so maybe that and the game designer gets
to do concept man code which is great
they don't just have to be the
programmer and coming up with narrative
and story lines and well that's what my
university has told me that game design
it does anyways if you think it's
something else please write it down in
the comments cuz I need to know these
things
but yeah the futurism is very open at
the moment but I would love to work in a
games company just just to know what
it's like just to get a better idea
overall you know it's really difficult
to pigeonhole yourself isn't it
especially when you're just so
passionate about about the whole process
but I do know that I would much prefer
to do some sort of storyboarding
narrative work concept in all coding
over like three modelling and things
like that think I need some some kind of
free range - a little bit of extent even
if it's just every now and then I just
get to kind of think of a new character
that could possibly be in the game or a
new storyline arcs that could possibly
happen that would keep my flame ignited
that is all I've got time for if you
would like to hear more about the
progression of my third year in
university please do check out that
second channel I've already got a video
up there with the character artist
Tabitha where we talk about our games so
far and yeah I'll be working on that
manically I forget but from Christmas I
am sure so I'm sure you'll hear more
about that hope you enjoy this hope it
was insightful and have a lovely day or
evening bye